hi I just want to thank everyone who
took the time to comment on my rant
about how movies like despicable me 2
are proof that Hollywood has gone soft
on super villains a lot of you agreed
with me that movies have present super
villains as secretly having a heart of
gold are lowing our children into a
false sense of security DJ square at
eight rights last time I checked the
classic Bond villain was named
Goldfinger not gold heart preach it DJ
squared aid the commenter Steven his
idiot totally agrees that Hollywood is
trying to shift our sympathies he writes
I actually left Man of Steel feeling bad
for Zod see that's how they get you I
myself left Man of Steel feeling bad for
the tens of thousands of civilians who
must have died in that endless final
battle ah to commenter Henry gone crazy
rights has no one realized that even
Star Wars did this when Vader killed the
Emperor that's a really good point he's
actually the archetypal villain and you
couldn't really call darth vader a wussy
Gotham's Black Knight rights did we ever
consider that the guy in this vid could
be a gulp bad guy look Gotham's Black
Knight if it's bad to fight against the
moral relativity of super villains then
I don't want to be a good guy several of
you suggested that I look like grew from
the despicable Me movies grew from the
despicable Me movies is totally bald and
he has a fat round face in a sharp
pointy nose I don't have a sharp pointy
nose thanks for your comments keep
watching and keep commenting on the wire
channel there's a lot of stuff I'm angry
about
what's getting under your skin make a
video and let me know everyone's got an
angry nerd in them